♪ ♪
>> Jesse: DAY 24 THE PARTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN OF THE
FUNDING FOR BORDER WALL.
THE PRESIDENT HUNKERING DOWN IN
D.C. OVER THE WEEKEND, WILLING
TO WORK ON A COMPROMISE, JUAN.
ABOUT 30 DEMOCRATS LEFT THEM
HANGING, CHOOSING TO TAKE OFF
FOR A WINTER RETREAT IN
PUERTO RICO.
THE PRESIDENT BLASTING DEMOCRATS
EARLIER TODAY.
>> I'VE BEEN HERE ALL WEEKEND.
A LOT OF THE DEMOCRATS WEREN'T
PUERTO RICO AND CELEBRATE
SOMETHING.
I DON'T KNOW HIM.
MAYBE THEY WERE CELEBRATING THE
SHUTDOWN.
WE HAVE A VERY BIG CRISIS,
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS OF THE
BORDER.
WE HAVE A PRIORITY.
IF THE SAFETY OF OUR NATION.
THE SOUTHERN BORDER HAS BEEN
HORRIBLE FOR DECADES.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE SUCCESS OF
OUR COUNTRY IT'S NOW AT A LEVEL
THAT WE CANNOT PUT UP WITH.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
WE NEED THEIR VOTES.
OTHERWISE WE CAN SOLVE IT.
LET'S SEE IF THEY CAN LEAD.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY CAN LEAD
BUT WE ARE GOING TO SOON FIND
OUT.
>> Jesse: REPUBLICAN
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
SUGGESTING THE PRESIDENT OPEN
THE GOVERNMENT FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME IN ORDER TO
NEGOTIATE A SOLUTION.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT'S RESPONSE
TO THAT.
>> IT WAS A SUGGESTION LINDSEY
MADE.
I DID REJECTED.
I'M NOT INTERESTED.
I WANT TO GET IT SOLVED.
I DON'T WANT TO JUST DELAY IT.
>> Jesse: LET'S GO BACK TO THE
PUERTO RICO TRIP.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE THE
PICTURE.
SENATOR MENENDEZ FROM NEW JERSEY
SHIRTLESS.
THERE HE IS BY THE BEACH.
TALKING THE TALK.
LOTION, DAIQUIRIS.
>> Greg: THANK GOD WE HAVE THE
LORD ASSURED
>> Jesse: HE'S FRESH OFF A
SCANDAL.
I THINK REPORTER SHOULD LOOK
INTO THAT AS OPPOSED TO THE
RUSSIA COLLISION SITUATION.
THERE'S MEAT ON THOSE BONES.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT MENENDEZ.
>> Dana: HAVING JUST COME OFF
THE ETHICAL PROBLEM, I WOULD
ASSUME THE TRIP THAT THEY TRIED
TO ADOPT ALL OF THEIR LETTER
EYES.
THERE IS A PERCEPTION PROBLEM.
IF I WERE THE DEMOCRATS, I MIGHT
SAY WE ARE IN PUERTO RICO, THE
PLACE YOU SAID YOU WERE GOING TO
TAKE FUNDS FROM HURRICANE RELIEF
TO PAY FOR THE WALL.
THAT'S WHY WERE HERE.
>> Jesse: DON'T TELL THEM
THAT, DANA.
>> Dana: CAN I MENTION
SOMETHING THE PRESIDENT SAID
TODAY.
IN THE LAST WEEK, IF THE
DEMOCRATS WERE WILLING TO TAKE
THE A LA CARTE MENU THAT HE
MENTIONED IN THESE INTERVIEWS,
THESE APPEARANCES.
IT'S THE MAKING FOR GOOD,
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
BILL.
LAST WEEK HE SAID THE H1B VISAS,
THE BEST, BRIGHTEST, SMARTEST.
DON'T GO ANYWHERE ELSE.
COME HERE AND WILL GIVE YOU
PERMANENT CITIZENSHIP.
THAT WASN'T ON THE TABLE BEFORE.
TODAY WHEN HE WAS TALKING TO
FARMERS, HE SAID I KNOW UNION
WORKERS.
THEY ALL STARTED CHEERING.
I'M GLAD I BROUGHT IT UP.
I WILL MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE
WORKERS.
LAST WEEK HE SAID HE WOULD DO
DACA.
FOR $5 BILLION FOR BORDER
SECURITIES WHICH DEMOCRATS
ALREADY SAID THEY WERE FOR, WHY
NOT TAKE HIM UP ON THESE THINGS
HE'S WILLING TO    TO DO?
>> Jesse: BECAUSE THEY ARE
WORKING ON THEIR TANS.
GREG, ARE THEY GOING TO PAY THE
PRICE FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
IF THE REPUBLICANS HAD GONE
TANNING IN PUERTO RICO OR
ANYWHERE, THEY WOULD'VE BEEN HIT
HARD.
>> Greg: VACATIONS ARE BAD FOR
POLITICIANS BECAUSE THERE IS
ALWAYS SOMETHING GOING ON THAT'S
SERIOUS.
IT'S REALLY GOOD OPTICS TO SEE A
POLITICIAN WITHOUT HIS CLOTHES
ON.
BUREAUCRATS SHOULD BE FULLY
CLOTHED AT ALL TIMES.
THAT'S JUST FOR ME.
CAN I RESPOND?
I WAS LISTENING TO HOWARD STERN
TODAY AND HE EXPRESSED AN
ARGUMENT THAT I'VE HEARD BEFORE
ABOUT WHY WALLS DON'T WORK.
HE THINKS BECAUSE OF TUNNELS.
I'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT THIS
AND I GO YOU CAN ARGUE THAT
TUNNELS ARE PROOF THAT WALLS
WORK BECAUSE IT FORCES THE
CRIMINAL TO ENGAGE IN RISKIER,
MORE INVOLVED, TIME-CONSUMING
ENDEAVORS.
YOU COULD USE THE SAME ARGUMENT
WHY WOULD I BUY A LOT FOR MY
BIKE IF SOMEONE HAS BOLT
CUTTERS.
THE REDUCE THE RISK OF YOUR BIKE
GETTING STOLEN, THE SAME WAY
THAT WALLS REDUCE THE RISK OF
CROSS OVER.
THIS GOES BACK TO LEGAL PORTS OF
ENTRY, DRUGS, ALL DETERRENCE DUE
TO HIS FINAL EFFORTS OF THE
CRIMINALS INTO MORE DIFFICULT,
LABOR-INTENSIVE ARENAS.
THAT'S THE SUCCESS.
WALLS, TUNNELS OR NO TUNNELS.
>> Jesse: IF HOWARD IS
LISTENING.
>> Greg: THAT WAS MY GENTLE
RESPONSE.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THE OPTICS AND GREG'S
AMAZING ANALYSIS OF THE TUNNEL?
>> Katie: I AGREE WITH HIS
ANALYSIS ABOUT POLITICIANS
HAVING THEIR CLOTHES ON,
ESPECIALLY BOB MENENDEZ, HAS HAD
SOME PROBLEMS WITH THE ISLANDS
IN THE PAST.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD BE MORE
CAREFUL.
WASHINGTON, D.C., IS VERY QUIET
RIGHT NOW I DEMOCRATS WHO
CLAIMED TO BE FIGHTING FOR
MIDDLE-CLASS GOVERNMENT WORKERS
WHO SKIPPED THEIR FIRST
PAYCHECK, IT'S ONE THING TO SKIP
ONE PAYCHECK.
IF YOU SKIP ANOTHER ONE, THAT'S
THE ENTIRE MONTH.
IT CREATES MORE PROBLEMS THAN
YOU HAVE THE FIRST TIME.
FOR THEM TO BE ON THE BEACH
MOTIONING UP -- WHILE THEY ARE
PARTYING WITH LOBBYISTS WHO MAKE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., AS A RESULT
OF THESE CONTRACTS, IT LOOKS BAD
AND HYPOCRITICAL ON TOP OF ALL
THE ISSUES THEY ARE NOT COMING
TO THE TABLE ON.
WHEN IT COMES TO REJECTING
LINDSEY GRAHAM'S SOLUTION, THE
PRESIDENT ALREADY PUT IT ON THE
TABLE WITH NANCY PELOSI IN THE
OVAL OFFICE AND SAID IF I OPEN
UP THE GOVERNMENT IN 30 DAYS,
WILL YOU GIVE ME SOME FUNDING
FOR THIS BARRIER OR WALL AND SHE
SAID NO.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ALREADY SAID IT
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU OPEN UP
THE GOVERNMENT.
WERE TALKING ABOUT $5 BILLION.
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
26 BILLION, AS DANA SAID.
THEY PUT SO MUCH ON THE TABLE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE IN TERMS OF
COMPROMISE, NOT EVEN FOR THE
ENTIRE SECTION OF THE WALL THEY
ARE LOOKING FOR.
IT'S A TINY PORTION OF WHAT HE'S
ACTUALLY ASKING FOR.
>> Juan: THE PRESIDENT HAD A
DEAL ON THE TABLE THAT HE
REJECTED THAT WOULD HAVE GIVEN
THE DREAMERS AND SOME OTHER
PEOPLE PROTECTIVE STATUS, PART
OF A DEAL IN EXCHANGE FOR THE
WALL.
STEVE MILLER AND THE PRESIDENT
SAID NO, WE WANT TO CUT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION BY HALF.
THE SECOND THING TO SAY IS WITH
REGARD TO THE REPUBLICAN EFFORT
ON GOING OUT TO GET SOME KIND OF
NEGOTIATION ON THE HILL, WHAT
YOU HEARD FROM PEOPLE LIKE CHRIS
COONS ON FOX NEWS SUNDAY
YESTERDAY, BUT WE NEED TO
NEGOTIATE BUT WE NEED SOMEONE
WHO IS RELIABLE.
THE PRESIDENT SHIFTS IN TERMS OF
WHAT HE WANTS AND DOESN'T WANT.
EVEN HIS TOP AIDES CAN'T BE
CONFIDENT AS TO WHAT WILL MAKE A
DEAL.
FINALLY, THIS IS A DEMOCRATIC
CRITIQUE.
I THINK THERE IS A SHOW OF
"HAMILTON."
LIN-MANUEL MIRANDA SHOW.
A LOT OF POLITICIANS HAVE GONE
DOWN.
REPUBLICANS HAVE RETREATS AND
SUNNY PLACES.
>> Katie: IN THE MIDDLE OF A
SHUTDOWN?
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE DOING THIS JANUARY BUT
THEY ARE SCHEDULED TO HAVE A
RETREAT.
>> Jesse: THEIR SHIRTS ARE ON.
I THINK THIS IS AN EFFORT.